[Musique]
pouvez-vous m'aider à tout mettre ensemble, ils
faisaient partie d'un groupe de personnes qui marchent
vers le nord parce que nous nous demandions pourquoi
un autre groupe de personnes et marche sait que
nous allons tous mourir d'accord le premier
jour où nous aimerions être  le sentier à
midi fait autant de terrain que possible
avant la tombée de la nuit,
nous avons eu la chance
de prendre une légende et de la transformer en
histoire enregistrée un nom de mère survit à
Rory en ce moment soixante-cinq miles à l'intérieur de
la route de briques jaunes comment vous sentez-vous  bien,
votre sœur dit ici que les instruments ont
été éteints ouais mais je n'ai pas été des gens
un frère croyait que c'était la route de l'
été
quel est votre plan n'a pas de plan je
pense que nous devrions continuer vers le nord mais que se passerait-il
si les gens commençaient à oublier le  chemin du retour
à qui nous étions nous allons commencer cette chose
j'ai fait un rêve nous avons fait tout le chemin du
retour et les herbes noires ce gars avait
tort
cette route est tout
[Musique]